for the left-hander john means
has been the orioles best starter this
year oddly enough they have not won in
one of his starts since the 31st of july
the lefty now facing nikki lopez nicki
had two more hits last night he has five
in the series
and that is belted to right field
and that is gone into the seats can i
say get him salvy
how about nikki
he almost had one last night but he hit
it up against that big scoreboard and
this time he got it
to the
over the eight foot wall in right center
field he just turned on it
there he is turns on it caught it
perfectly that ball was right down the
middle of the plate
belt
yes get up ball is right and it did
and they'll get a look at carlos
hernandez for the second time this year
well
first time carlos hernandez was just
kind of feeling his way around was his
first start
and now
they're going to face a guy hopefully
who's on top of his game
mullins hits it to deep center field
taylor takes a look at the wall and he's
got it
strike three over the outside edge
hit well center field but taylor is
there
so hernandez gets the o's one two three
and at the end of one the royals lead
one nothing
royals he had a walk and now hunter
dozier comes up to the plate
closure drives one on a one-two means
has his hands on his hips hoping cedric
mullins will take it away and he will
right in front of the wall
the royals strand two and the game stays
one nothing
back to back two out singles for the o's
and jamai jones will look to get on base
for the second time in the series
and jones hits it hard to the left side
severino does not run well they're gonna
wave him home here's ben attendee's
throw it is
in time
so third base coach tony manzolino with
the number nine hitter coming up
gambled
and sent his catcher
severino who was gunned down by ben and
tendee to end the second good throw by
ben and tende in an excellent tag by
salvador perez
and the royals deny the orioles here in
the second inning
[Applause]
salvador perez a ground ball to third
could be two gutierrez won jones with a
whole bunch of time to first
and a double play to end to seven pitch
inning for means john means to andrew
benintendi who swats the first pitch out
to center field center camon's charging
back at the track love overhead makes
the catch on the run
mullins gives ben attendee a little of
his own medicine but the defense has
never slipped all year long and he got a
really good jump on that ball
and now a bouncer up the middle and
that's whit
in time
so hernandez works around two walks the
orioles have stranded five
up all golfed out to left and
dj got there in time
slip sliding away dj stewart grabs the
second out
he's hitting 276 and he went down and
got a ball it wasn't even a strike and
hit it pretty good out the left field a
solid play by dj stewart and johnny
means appreciates it
out over the plate and well hit to left
field ben and tendee
will make the play
ball is not carrying and santander who
plays here every day even
seems surprised that was an out
[Music]
[Applause]
chopped out to alberto who throws from a
puddle
carlos hernandez certainly has had
better outings in his last several
starts
but he's doing what it takes
to stay in the game here he's
doing a nice job defense is making some
plays behind him a lot of fly balls they
play stewart to pull three infielders on
the right side and a hanging breaking
ball hit deep to center back goes taylor
in front of the fence he'll pull it down
and another long fly ball is shy of the
fence and stays in the yard and all of a
sudden carlos hernandez has retired
eight in a row we go to the seventh at
camden yards the royals lead one nothing
john has thrown 71 pitches so
he's got a chance to work deep into this
game
monday strikes out on a cutting
curveball from means strikeout number
five
especially against the right-handers
that breaking ball has been outstanding
it is in the zone and it is gone
taylor in the air to right
[Music]
two down for alberto
[Applause]
there will be no three walk game for
alberto here
cedric mullins puts it away and john
means completes seven innings for the
first time since may a one-nothing game
at the stretch
and mateo didn't get out of the box so
it ends up being an easy play
that
there's
mud kicked up behind him but
carlos santana was ready to apply the
tag but there was nobody there
there you go
[Music]
hopefully fine i don't know if nicki
would have thrown him out he's has elite
speed but he
got a break there
you're talking about his speed
line toward right center field but
slicing
caught by santondar dozier tags and he's
going to be in there
somebody to take a chance in a
productive out
yeah
just like
playing outside in the mud and nikki
against lefty john means hit a line
drive over the wall in right center
field
and now he'll ground it through the
right side and the royals take a
two-nothing lead in the eighth inning
there's your bus driver for the night
and a line drive is off of jones glove
nicki will stop at second base
and the royals have two on with one out
as salvi gets his first hit of the night
yep he'll take it
nice hops by jones
there's a base hit off of jones glove
and that'll get nikki lopez to the plate
benetendi
drives in another run in the series he
has seven rbis
in the series the royals have added two
and they lead three nothing in the
eighth
a one
hit on the ground at third base
gutierrez looks home he'll throw onto
first base and retire santana but perez
jogs in with an insurance run
and it's now a four to nothing royals
lead hunter dozier
one for three
and he bangs this one deep to left
that's way back and that one is long
gone
home run hunter dozier
that is his first since august 18th and
he gives the royals a commanding six
nothing lead
oh now he's gonna be a catcher
look out
no collision tonight and with that
the royals
shut out the orioles six nothing with
royals pitching
retiring 17 of the last 18.